(funky music)
- Hey guys, I'm Jade.
And today we're gonna find
out if we dance better
when we're sober or when
we're a little tipsy.
- I've danced pretty much my whole life,
it doesn't mean I'm good.
But dance doesn't have to be
good, it just has to be pure
and from the heart.
- I think I'm gonna be better drunk.
That's the honest truth.
And then you just, like,
let loose, feel the vibes.
- We needed some unbiased
opinions to judge this fairly.
So we brought in some
professional dancers.
- I'm Bex Robinson.
I have been dancing since
I was two, so 20 years.
I love dance because it's a
form of expression and freedom
and for me it's a way to
communicate without saying words.
- What's going on everybody,
my name is Eugene Cho.
I also go by @bboylooselee.
I am 25 years old and I've
been dancing for 13 years.
- In round one they're gonna dance
to three songs completely sober,
and they are gonna drink a
little bit, take a couple shots,
then they're gonna the same
three songs again but drunk.
(R&B song)
- I don't know what I'm doing!
(funk music)
Yo, this is the only move I know.
(dancehall music)
- Dance like nobody's watching.
- Oh that's the problem,
you guys are watching.
(laughs)
Oh my god, I don't know, I'm like...
Maybe with my drinks I'll be better.
(funky music)
- Oh, wow!
I did better than I thought, all right!
- I gave him a 7.5 because
I thought that he was still
on the music even though
he was, like, super tired towards the end.
(bell dings)
Gave her a 8.5 because she's
on beat the whole time,
and also she's storytelling
which a lot of people don't do.
(bell dings)
- (laughs) That's very kind.
- You use your space
great, you just gotta get
out of your head.
So I'm excited to see
what the tequila does.
(dance music)
(people cheering)
- (slowly speaking) We're getting drunk!
(R&B music)
(funk music)
- It's the Michael Jackson.
(dancehall music)
- [Brenda] Oh, watch it!
(upbeat music)
(bell dings)
- Yeah!
- I give an eight 'cause his musicality
was actually a little bit better
and also he had more confidence.
So I gave him an eight.
(bell dings)
- Aww, shit.
- I feel like your
confidence in the last one
was, like, up there, and you
were in your head this one.
- [Jade] Brenda, look at your score!
- What!
(bell dings)
- (squeals) Oh my god!
- All of the confidence that you had...
First of all, different human,
right now than it was before.
And those hips, are you kidding me?
Like, I... (stammers)
That's what I have to say.
(Brenda squeals)
- [Clark] She made it rain.
- [Bex] Yeah, yeah, it was good.
(funky music)